[Music]
let's talk about wanderlust that this
movie decided that briefly you and your
husband is played by Paul Rudd you
decide to you have to move you have a
baby cannot afford he gets fired we have
to move out of the city to Atlanta to
stay with his horrible horrible brother
beautifully played by Ken Marino and we
and on our way we stopped at a what we
think is a B&B and it turns out to be
this crazy communist yes it's a
communist there's it's very hippie
dippie ish this commune and it's
insanity well there's a and there's a
nudist character in it and played by an
actor a very funny guy Joe yeah Joe lo
Truglio and he is fully frontally nude
nudists and it's yes and in quite a
shocking way jarring isn't it it quite
jarring and then fascinating but you're
looking at it and I'm thinking was that
real or what's happening there please
yeah that's good to know it's it is not
real it's not real no you're not seeing
his actual male member no but you are
seeing other male members and the
nudists that actually did were
background yes later on you see that
slow-motion shot where they're all
running yes yeah but Joe no Joe well you
get used to it was within ten minutes we
were having normal conversations and he
was getting touch-ups it was not it was
normal so there'd be special effects
people that would come in and work on
this device that he has oh yeah him this
person yeah it's just on the eyes focus
on the eyes focus on the eyes it was a
hard mantra to get cuz you'd want to you
know it can't help it's natural its yeah
hi nice to meet you
this was it's set on a farm
did you work did you shoot this in in
Clarksville Georgia Georgia have a
beautiful most beautiful countryside and
we were there the most gorgeous time of
the year was just going from salt or
summer to fall and so we had some lake
time and we were all on this lake
I mean read to you by does not matter oh
no okay it's the it's the way it is okay
just before Andy when we go after you
not to speak to her just ease dropping
basically exactly it's creepy it's pervy
the way he's doing it look you go ahead
and finish yeah
there's a scene on the farm where you
milk a goat
and it looks like you really milk the
goat I did really milk a goat
have you done it wasn't milking yeah
that was horrible I had not I'd done it
once at the at the camera test and I
couldn't do it because it was seemed
really too intense right it was you'd
really grab at it and it was like I'm
the city girl I'm not that's not my
thing right right so but then I was like
during the day I had to get prepped and
I just went for it and I was like bite
the bullet let's just milk this thing
right and it was did you make you feel
like okay I could live on a voice you
did it no no you don't ever want to do
that again I wouldn't be opposed to it
right but it wouldn't be like I'm gonna
move to a farm and milk goats I'm
shocked that you're not gonna do that
are you is that make me a bad person yes
it does yes it does we're very
judgmental show here we have a clip here
and I believe this is a scene where you
mistakenly it's almost like you're
tripping oh I am your trip yeah you are
tripping mistakes here I forget what
happens something you drink something
it's been City weirdest we do a truth
circle and we have this great scene with
the whole cast and then we all end up
having a hallucinogenic trip it's very
funny it's a very funny scene the part
where there's a lot of special effects
where you were seeing what you're seeing
but I think this is the effects of you
taking this let's take a look at this
clip from wanderlust I can fly I believe
I can fly
metaphorically I believe you can fly
literally you can't fly I believe I can
fly if you're gonna get literal with an
r kelly song let's do trapped in the
closet you can't break your neck if
you're trapped in a closet just watch me
no no no no I believe
[Applause]
see you can't fly I always believed